madame lucas bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous n'ont pas tous les
jours on est donc aux côtés des gens
dans le besoin des personnes âgées des
personnes handicapées aujourd'hui c'est
différent nous sommes en confinement
nous sommes dans le cadre d'une épidémie
comment ces personnes fragiles que vous
suivez quotidiennement aujourd'hui gère
cette crise alors mais tout d'abord je
voulais vous remercier de nous laisser
la parole parce que nous sommes
personnel soignant mais oubliés puisque
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas
de masque pas de gang pas de gel faisant
soi disant parti donc des personnels
soignants mais nous n'avons aucune
protection toutes les pharmacies ne
refuse ces masques
la semaine dernière on march tournis
trois masques ffp2 donc en sachant
qu'ils ont une durée de vie est réduite
moi c'est mon conjoint qui est policier
qui m'a fourni ces masques donc en fait
on doit choisir et le problème c'est
qu'on ait tout dans ce cas là on
intervient auprès de personnes qui sont
des malades des personnes âgées qui ont
qui sont immunodéprimés et nous on
arrive avec potentiellement ce virus en
tant que porteur c'est donc le problème
se pose là c'est que en un moment aucune
aucune protection et qu'on se met en
danger on met en danger notre famille on
l'est on met en danger aussi les
personnes chez qui l'emmenait
interviennent donc là actuellement il ya
une forme de plaquiste riche et tout le
monde et non je vois qu'on ait beaucoup
de difficultés puisque on a énormément
d'intervention pour les familles
prennent le relais quand elles peuvent
et non que l'on il me manque beaucoup
beaucoup d'heures dont vous avez du mal
à vous avez donc du mal à respecter les
gestes barrières parce que vous manquez
de moyens de protection mais vous
confirmer quand même allés visiter ces
personnes a dit fragile
ah ben oui mais déjà les gestes barrière
se laver les mains oui ok respecter une
distance de 20 mètres c'est impossible
quand vous devez lever une personne
faire une toilette par une douche
l'habillage
donnez préparer le repas les aider pour
manger c'est totalement impossible quoi
donc on est vraiment en contact on en
est à rapprocher de ces personnes et
avec sans protection on a beau se laver
les mains mais bon c'est pas ça qui va
tout va qui va faire le reste quoi mais
est ce que ces personnes fragiles sont
elles munis de masques de protection
non non on en a pas nous elles n'ont pas
non plus ou alors vraiment elles ont
réussi un avoir auprès de leur médecin
traitant qui le rend passé en deux camps
mais c'est tout et c'est personnes
estime a besoin fragiles ou handicapées
âgées confinés à leur domicile
comment psychologiquement à vivre cette
crise abbas est très compliqué parce que
notre hall aussi bas c'est de maintenir
le lien social
sauf que le lien social et non plus pour
la plupart quand on le peut on les amène
avec nous faire des courses des rangs
des roues un peu demain choix
l'expérience à fait possible donc c'est
vraiment très compliqué de leur
expliquer et de leur faire comprendre
que l'on est obligé de rester à
l'intérieur
quand le moment de deux pauses espèces
en soins ce recul quoi donc on a
vraiment le moins de contacts possibles
emilie lucas merci beaucoup et on vous
souhaite beaucoup de courage beaucoup de
forces dans cette épreuve dans cette
crise
je rappelle que vous êtes auxiliaires de
vie et chaque jour au contact des
personnes fragiles merci pour votre
travail merci d'avoir et tour direct
avec nous